how's it going guys today we are gonna
build a simple C plus plus program and
I'm gonna do it on the Linux command
line here so I'm on my Windows computer
but I'm using WSL and I'm on Ubuntu here
in this console so we're just gonna do
everything in the console and using
Linux commands these will probably work
on Mac of course you got to set up your
environment I should have GCC I should
have G plus plus these are just required
for compiling and they're the versions
in case you're curious so all right
let's go let's see where are we right
now if I print my working directory I'm
just um at this slash so I'm just gonna
type CD for change directory and with no
um whatever command to follow it's just
going to take me to my home directory
which you can see here so uh first thing
we're going to do is we're going to make
a directory with the make your command
and I'm just going to call this SRC I
think for now and we're going to go into
SRC this kind of just going to be a
place where I keep my projects now I'm
going to make another directory and I'm
just going to call this one uh timer
demo I suppose
so this code will be posted on my GitHub
course link below but yeah we're going
to walk through it I'm going to explain
everything I can alright so we're going
to go into this timer demo folder now we
have some options naturally we just want
to compile with GCC or G plus plus for
the C plus plus stuff and we're going to
use C plus plus but we could abstract
that away and just use cmake instead not
going to do that here uh just because uh
we're gonna simplify it even more CMAC
confuses people sometimes for some
reason if they want just the raw you
know this is just the raw stuff so what
I'm saying all right so let's make
directory again here and this time
we're gonna make a source folder for
timer actually let's just keep it all
single level no folders so we're going
to make files let's make a main file
we're going to use the touch command and
put make.cbp there now if we do an LS
um we should see that there's a main as
we do
so we're going to need a couple other
files let's just make a timer dot h now
in this particular program we're going
to design it in such a way uh let me
lowercase timer we're going to design it
in such a way that everything builds
into the main so we're going to actually
put our definitions in this dot h file
but you might want to separate those out
if you're doing it differently more on
that if you want to hear more on that
just let me know
essentially here we want to open up our
main we could do so using them
and let's get going here go into insert
mode and just make an INT main we're not
going to take in any inputs on the main
although normally you would
we don't really need to do anything here
so I'm just going to return a zero and
then we are going to write and quit and
our main is saved we could now compile
if we wanted to actually let's go in
here and just put in a hello world very
good and we will write and quit on that
as well okay and then from here we can
actually go ahead and compile we can go
g plus plus main dot CPP and that will
just compile that C plus plus file with
all the defaults and that's going to
make an a DOT out so if we do an LS
we'll see an a DOT out you can see it
here and from there we can just run it
by going dot slash that is a forward
slash a DOT out and there it goes hello
world so there you go first C plus plus
program okay so let's now make our timer
let's go into vim and go into timer.h
very good go in insert mode do your
pragma once at the top to make sure it
doesn't ever get double included and
let's start making a class we'll just
call it timer with capital T in this
class we're going to use
Chrono
so we need to be sure to include that
that's all we need Chrono is the header
from standard template library that
helps do stuff with time now in our
timer we're just going to make a very
simple stopwatch that you can reset and
we're also going to be able to grab the
Delta from like a tick so we can see
what it was since last time if we want
as well
okay so in this we're going to hold some
variables privately and we're going to
expose a few main functions so if we
think about this a little bit and what
we want to do exactly that should all
somewhat come to us but basically well
when we start the timer we want it to
start at zero
or to put it another way at the time
that it is you'll just make a time stamp
of the current time because well you'll
see shortly here let's hypothesize
though so we're going to need some kind
of Constructor and we're going to need
let's go ahead and make these public
apparently I need to edit my Vim
settings here to do tabbing and spacing
as I prefer
but that's okay we're gonna want a way
to reset the timer with reset
I should preface this with a void and I
should preface this one with nothing for
this Constructor but we're going to
Define them here so we can go ahead and
put our brackets in here and we want a
tick function that's basically going to
tick the timer
and maybe Tick's not the best
name for it it's more like a get Delta
time so we'll rename this get Delta time
okay and we're also just gonna want a
elapsed time now elapsed time is going
to basically be how long it's been going
total we're going to call this git and I
think I'm going to change up a few other
names here I think I'm going to change
this reset to restart okay and let's
hold some variables so I haven't really
talked about the exact design of this
that's because I haven't written it down
it's just kind of in my head we're going
to keep track of some time points and
this is not Chrome it's Corona so here's
where we're using just a type from the
Chrono library and it's a system clock
time point and we're just going to have
this be our start time I'm going to just
preface this with underscore starts
yeah that's fine we're going to need a
few more of these so we can use some C
plus plus features and just put a comma
here and have a current
could declare them on new lines it's up
to you how you want to do that and we're
also going to have a last time
and the last time is essentially going
to be for the tick or I guess this would
be better as like last Delta
tick
so we have a start time we have a
current time and we have a last Delta
tick and we're also just going to keep
track of the Delta time variable
as a duration because these are all just
time points they're basically a time
stamp and
a clock so with those though you can
always calculate uh what you want to get
so that's all we really need to keep
track of let's also make a narration
here it's another type from the Chrono
library and we'll just call it Delta
time sure okay so we just need to
initialize all these correctly and we
should be smooth sailing so we got to
think how do we want these time points
and this duration to initialize and well
time points why not now as in the time
created and for the Delta time why not
zero sounds good so we're just going to
put these all in here and we're just
gonna chain them together since they're
all going to be the same and they're all
the same variable type we can do that
and we're going to pull from the Chrono
library and just get the system clock
now
and that'll just set them all to the
same time
which is whenever this is created let's
go ahead and set our Delta time to well
you would think you'd be able to do zero
but remember this is a special type
coming out of Chrono
and it's a duration of type float so we
gotta make sure we actually use that
type as well when we're setting it I do
not believe it has an overload to just
take an integer and assume it's the
right type although they could in theory
expand it to do that if they wanted they
being whoever works on the standard
template Library not that I'm
recommending doing that
up to you guys because as you know the
more you add the heavier your software
gets so there's always a cost okay
that's good for the initialization let's
go ahead and make a restart function I
think when we restart we just want to
set the start time to now I think that
should be sufficient could in theory
reset all the other timers but they will
update on the next calls of these other
functions anyway so I think this is fine
that should be good enough for a restart
function and let's go ahead and make our
get Delta time now our git Delta time is
essentially going to uh
perform a a tick of the system since the
last tick well since it's going to start
out as the
current time and it's going to compare
to the current time
it's not really going to work with this
the start time at all this Delta time
only cares about when was the last time
you checked a tick and what is it now so
that makes sense awesome let's code it
up so we're going to update the current
time because that matters here current
time equals Chrono now
custom clock now and then we're just
going to update this Delta time that's
going to equal well the current time you
subtract what it was the last time we
checked which would be the last Delta
tick and that will return a duration so
Delta time is updated and now as we're
doing this we want to go ahead and
update now
the last Delta tick was at this current
time we'll need this for the next time
we run through this function for
repeated Delta updates last Delta tick
equals current time and then we do need
to return a float here so let's go ahead
and do that it's Delta time now Delta
time is a Chrono duration float so we
need to call a function in that one
called count which will return the float
so the get tilt Delta time function is
good let's go ahead and move down to get
elapsed time now this is just going to
get the time since the start so anytime
we call this we want to be sure and go
ahead and make sure our current time is
relevant and we do that by setting it to
now as you would expect and then from
here we want to get the elapsed time
basically now this is just a temporary
variable so we're going to clear it
right here
and we'll just call it lapsed time and
now this is going to be from our start
time minus the current time
and then we return last time but since
we need it as a float and that's a
duration we need to call the count
function on the return
all right looking pretty good let's go
ahead and press escape to get out of the
insert mode and type in the characters
you see at the bottom there to write it
out and then quit
now let's go back into our main
and add it here so we'll go into insert
mode I've been include and in double
quotes that file timer.h that's going to
grab all the Declarations and
definitions and build them here so
instead of saying C out uh hello world
let's say hello timer
and let's go ahead and test this timer
out
so we know that we have to declare a
timer naturally
and it's with capital T because we're
declaring that class let's just call it
our timer sounds good we know that when
we declare it it's going to call that
Constructor and set it to now so let's
just do some testing let's go into a
while loop and we'll say while our timer
Dot
I don't know we'll say it runs for like
10 seconds or something all right so
we'll do get I guess it would be get
running time but we call that git
elapsed time
while that is less than 10. we're going
to use a dot f to make sure it compares
to a float on that 10.
so while it's less than 10 let's do a
thing so why don't we just see out the
elapsed time let's call
our timer not elapsed time but Delta
time I guess
get Delta time and let's put a new line
character there so we should see a bunch
of Delta times and after 10 seconds it
should exit and that's all the program
does it's essentially a little test for
it so we're gonna
do the same thing here a write and a
quit
on that file and now let's compile them
all together
for agma once in main file really
oh it's from the include okay I'm not
sure why that's a strange warning I've
never seen that but it doesn't seem to
give it a problem well you're not
necessarily supposed to compile with the
dot h files on here because they're
going to get included anyway when you're
compiling in this way that I'm doing it
here there are times when you do want to
specify the dot each files in your
Source but I don't want to get deep into
the Weeds on that because depends on how
you're programming all right so let's
just compile this main compiles with no
errors we can run this a DOT out and we
are getting some Delta times it's
should exit after 10 seconds of spamming
them very quickly and it's also doing
them in some kind of notation okay well
it's definitely going for more than 10
seconds so we may have coded something
wrong so let's stop our program by just
closing it oops do not close it I just
close by instance of WSL oopsie
and let's check out our
timer
I think what we've done here is we've
made a bit of a mistake I'm not 100 sure
but I think at this time shouldn't it be
the current time minus the start time
yeah
that's right so let's just flip that
around
and let's go back into our main and
instead of showing the Delta time as a
float well let's just not show so many
characters it's trying to show like uh
the signed scientific notation and it's
looking very confusing so uh maybe let's
just maybe let's just
see what the elapsed time is for now
because it should just be you know
steadily going up basically it'll be a
fine test for now all right let's make
sure we recompile and let's run the
program and there it is steadily going
up okay so that seems to work fine and
there it exits after 10 seconds as
expected just correcting the elapsed
time seem to fix that okay well now we
can actually check Delta time let's go
back into our main since it's our
eventually our test file tester program
and let's put this back to Delta time
write that out file it
run it and there's a bunch of Delta
times it should still exit after 10
seconds
so just make sure that happens yep
yeah these Delta times look terrible
just because how they're shown so we
could fix that with uh
well you might not need to fix it
depending on your program but as you can
see it's just scientific notation to
show a very small number because these
Delta times are going very very quickly
as this Loop is going very very quickly
so they're actually really small numbers
could tailor your C alt experience
foreign just putting it in here oh what
is it it's like standard iOS something
okay well the ultimate problem here was
this number is just so small this number
is just really really small uh because
you know Delta times going really fast
because our program isn't really doing
much work per update so it's able to go
this fast even single thread so uh even
when we set it to fixed and then set
precision and then set a fill
it still has trouble but I don't know
maybe we can set this to like nine
and maybe we'll be able to see something
it's a our Delta is happening very fast
okay well not that many nines geez
okay so let's try this one go ahead and
compile
rerun okay now we can actually see some
Delta values in there that we can read
okay we'll just keep this going with a
few little bonus things here at the end
uh as you can see I've got the comments
in there about basically what it does I
should probably write something up about
how to use it but I'm going to kind of
skip that
essentially okay restart restarts the
start time to now which basically resets
the elapsed time count yep simple enough
uh get Delta time Returns the amount of
time since the last tick simple enough
we could even probably say you know the
person might say what's a tick because
we don't really explain that in this
class so we could say since last fall to
this function sounds good to me then if
we go down a bit more we have a the get
elapsed time Returns the amount of time
since last reset uh I should probably
record that as restart since that's the
name of the function it does the
restarting okay and there we go good
enough for now so I just want to talk
about one last thing here and that's
like a case where I would use this
commonly so let me go back into my main
ensure we got this little example that's
all fine
let's just do it for one second now and
let's also set this Precision a little
lower maybe to seven feels fine get
Delta time let's actually do get elapsed
time here
okay and now let's just do a new
function so it's going to do that for
one second all right whatever that's
fine so if you were what would you use a
timer for right if you think about it
you're going to write some piece of
software why do you need a timer well
lots of reasons uh the most obvious one
to me that I use it most frequently for
is for basically for timeouts and things
you can think of these like cooldowns
you know when you press an ability in a
game it says you can't use it for 10
seconds that sort of thing but it's not
only useful in games sometimes you just
don't want things to be spammed in
general so if you've got something in
your program that you do not want to be
able to be spammed you can put that on a
cool down behind the scenes and you can
do that with the timer for example let's
say
uh let's make a run function here or not
a function but a loop I'm just making
this running Boolean so we have a way to
break out of it and we could say
let's only do something at the most once
every three seconds so we'll hard code
in this timer as I float
timeout that equals three seconds now
obviously you know these will be custom
or individual thing but this is just an
example of one we could say here
well let's make a timer for this you
know we got this timer up here I guess
we could just use the same timer because
we know that we can reset it by calling
the restart function so we'll just right
here go our timer dot restart and I
waited just the same one since we're in
the same scope but you could declare new
timers in different places and different
Scopes if you wanted to and if you
declare them statically well let's not
get into that
um but the point is you know you can
have more than one I'm just reusing the
same one because it's convenient but we
could say if our timer Dot
get elapsed time it's greater than three
seconds or it's greater than time out
rather here or the cooldown whatever you
want to call it greater than six seconds
three seconds let's just do a c out of
uh
three seconds left now what we could do
here you know we could go a whole crazy
Direction Where We Take a time stamp and
save it locally here and compare it or
we could just use the slope timer and go
restart again
so whenever
it goes for that timeout which is three
seconds it's going to restart and do it
over and over again and maybe we could
say no after we do that a few times
maybe we want to turn or something so
let's exit the program trying to come up
with a condition where we're done with
the program so let's just make an
integer here called elapsed counts
notice that this is in the Bible Loop
scope so
and we'll just we'll just take that up
you know plus plus every three seconds
so there we go we'll get a plus plus
every three seconds now in a game you
could work this as like maybe your
health goes up passively every three
seconds or five seconds or something or
your Mana it would be the same type of
setup you would get a little timer where
when it ticks because you don't you
don't want a Delta ticket that's like
every single frame but you might want to
take it every three seconds so you can
do something like this get every three
seconds and uh do a thing so that'll be
the point uh maybe we'll do a little
count here
I didn't put a new line and let others
see out so
this will be on the same line as that
previous one I'll put the new line here
and we'll also just do a little thing
just at the end of this while loop here
before it Loops again and we'll just say
if count or elapsed counts greater than
whatever we decide maybe we'll just do
it three times it's greater than three
well I guess that would be four times
since it's got to be greater than three
then we can set running equals false and
that'll essentially make it exit the
loop and we'll get out of here so with
that all programmed let's write and quit
do a new compile get a bunch of Errors
apparently we just spelled something
wrong
well we definitely spelled this variable
wrong collapsed counts here trying to
check for any other errors
I think we're good here oh we've got a
bracket somewhere messing everything up
so kind of important to check the top
one if compiling in this way okay yeah
it appears I accidentally deleted a
bracket here uh that's the main cause of
these errors
so now we can compile and we can run and
we should get our one second count there
and then going to that while loop doing
a lapsed count okay we can see here the
account is not taking up do you know why
so it's never going to exit because
count needs to get to 4 for it to exit
so we have a bit of a bug there let's go
ahead and stop the program and we'll go
ahead and fix this real quick uh
basically all we need to do is this
elapsed count every time this while loop
resets it reinstantiates and resets to
zero so that's why it just keeps going
to one because it keeps resetting to
zero so two different solutions we could
employ here we could make this static
that way it only ever instantiates once
which is fine in this case we could
optionally put it out of this while loop
scope and manage it that way uh I
personally am fine with it being static
here so let's just go ahead and
recompile that and go run we'll get our
one second of Delta times then our three
second ticks here and hopefully the
count works correctly it will so there
you go there's how to do some cool Downs
get the Delta times and some while loop
stuff and a basic coating of uh timer
obviously this is just a bit of
boilerplate there's a ton more you could
do and expand on it expand its
functionality and like I said you're
welcome to do so
so uh yeah all right I'll see you in the
next one peace out guys
foreign